yeah maybe i'll play some trio
i'm using using the using the chest to
warm up for
the legend of zelda
uh now wolf i i don't think i'll be
uploading
any of the nes stuff it's just going to
be on twitch
i
i did see from
i should probably join if i'm going to
join
i did see somebody clipped up
my uh my victory over mega man 2
difficult they titled it jerry pro gamer
i did i didn't i didn't catch who
clipped it
i thought that that was funny
my reaction was pretty
uh
pretty
fun to listen to
oh
slim
the late hit
ouch
hello hi he
okay we got we have action here
all right uh let's go with the sicilian
what's up dude
all right
oh that's a little unusual queen
recapture
um
could this be a little irritating i'm
gonna flick this one in
have the queen go back
okay
not quite sure who really benefits
i go fishing
i might go fishing
let me throw this one in
nah let's run with this
not too concerned about that
d6
is a good way to clog up the center
i'm expecting this knight's going to
want to move soon and then
f4 possibly
take with the pawn
stops this one
let me give her a kick i have this one
covered twice
is this queen not close to being trapped
all right let's start with this
oh
i was looking forward to a queen
exchange
feels comfortable
all right
see if we can get the queens off
a little surprised to see that one
this does force the queens off
and i think the main imbalance is that
my knight
is
in better position than this one
go with this
chop chop them on the night these tricks
shouldn't be working
oh
i missed that that was even a move okay
it's not that
big a deal oh so the queen exchange
could have been avoided
i think g3 is necessary
oh this really gives me the dark squares
all right
let's pivot
i probably am just gonna have to go back
yeah
not really going anywhere
okay
i'd like to force this because now i
could revisit the d4 square
i have the better bishop that's what i'm
looking forward to
i have a passer as well
i have a check here let me glue this guy
in for starters or
is it worthwhile to consider
now let's get this guy secure
and then maybe i can look at this move
with king
f6 maybe insert the check first might
this pawn
might it run away
let's go with this one
i have an in-between check
if capture or maybe even this first
okay
suppose i play this
let me take here
can't take with the queen because this
pond's too fast
okay
let's see how far can i go
i guess we begin with this one
i have to duck some checks
okay i'm not too concerned about that
one
let me i think the forcing the king to
the the back rank
is going to be useful
and i want to do this to cover that one
i don't want to
ensuing check
well i guess i'm hiding here so
i have to hurry up
as long as there's no perpetual not
seeing any perpetual
maybe starting with this is good
and then here
might have to run
yeah everything's defended
is it a perpetual
oh i could have blocked with my pawn
what am i doing
forgot that that guy's around
okay i think the checks are running out
getting this
using using the pawns against
white
two queens
got a square
i think that's it
oh i could have also captured the queen
it should just be made in a a couple
okay
i didn't think there would be a
perpetual
dr disrespect played some
qb for your niners
parcel hello
it was a it was clipped by joe bruin
okay
yeah i didn't i didn't take note i saw
it on my
i was fishing around i looked up mega
man 2.
on my phone and there was someone doing
a speed run
i learned a few tricks
man
those speed runners
are real masters at the game
these
pixel perfect jumps
left and right like it's nothing
uh let's go with this one
yeah it is dangerous to go alone what
what a line
i guess i'll start with this i'd like to
try and resolve this tension so
if i could establish a pawn on b4
that should resolve the tension
at the same time this
this this and then a
five
maybe i could play it as a gambit
i'll go this straight away instead of
moving my knight with b4
so my my reaction is going to be
to give up upon
and then move my knight
you know kind of lean on a lead in
development
yeah so here we are
um i i should maybe even consider knight
c3 come to think of it
it's double attack against the queen
so this is a square i could pivot about
on
could also flick in rook b1
uh let's go with rook b1
knight supports that
queen to one of these two i get another
tempo maybe she has to go home
so i still have this big space
now that there isn't as much pressure on
d4 i could go to this active post
there
okay
[Music]
i guess i support it
with my queen
and keep that one
watched over
maybe this wasn't so
wonderful
hello
med ben
spicy pickle hello
uh you know what let me initiate the
capture
who the knight has to take now
seems like it bishop takes i could take
with check
night night takes is at least defending
there this knight is unprotected
i've seen a wonderful way to take
advantage of it though
let's make some useful moves
bishop there
there maybe maybe flicking in this is
worthwhile
it's a stable oh giving me the dark
square bishop
i don't want to trade knights
so yeah let's let's get rid of that
bishop that wasn't just any bishop too
that was the good guy
so i guess from here i develop i want to
point it this week in square so
also queen takes a rook takes b i feel
like there should be some tactic nearby
for me
this uh lead in development maybe
maybe it's a good idea to put this
knight here first
knight c6 there's rook takes b6
okay so right about now i feel like
there should be a tactic chop chop check
oh this this bishop takes king takes
queen check
i think is working
the old attraction
saccharony the queen and knight should
be able to work
some magic
should be enough to deliver the mate
also have forks
king there
okay
oh no not down any material but
time is also a thing
pin the pawn
threaten the pawn
and now this check
i probably missed something
forks everywhere
what a pain this night is
oh now i'm getting this rook for free
another fork nearby
why didn't i give check
really messing this one up
okay should be able to pre-move
computers going
fast
no problems with the premiums there
chick gondol thank you for the primary
sub 69 months now appreciate it
castlevania 3 oh
you know i don't i've played castlevania
just the regular
but i never
i don't think i've ever defeated it i
guess i didn't enjoy it enough to
continue playing it
i think the games i i do
i don't know
am i only enjoying the games i can
defeat is that what it is
um
no that isn't the case actually
there exchange french let's put this guy
right here
that's an unusual post for the bishop
with this being an open file
typically the miners want to stay out of
the way because they're likely to have
some pressure on them eventually with
the major pieces
uh i think i'll play this one right away
this is a desirable exchange
bad for good
okay let's make some restrictive move
really didn't plan on making use of this
square with my queen knight anyhow
pawns are op yeah you must have missed a
last
couple streams
had a stream combo
chess
chess and nes
okay
i'll go ahead and initiate this one
and next up let me work on
this knight who is currently
well from whoa wait a second i didn't
realize white took away from the center
okay i don't think it should be too big
of a deal
the main difference in this position is
related to these knights
let's get this guy here
this guy needs some work
it's kind of out of play here
because of this structure alone
so i'm looking at getting to this square
and i might as well move forward in the
process at least point at something
though i don't know if i'm
100 sure that i want to
take the pawn if i can
um
let's go here
and i think
uh this knight can't go here right away
because i got a fork
should be working out i thought it would
be working out am i missing something
am i missing something maybe i'm missing
something
this this
takes knight takes rook takes rook takes
i feel like i should be good with the
two minor pieces there
i guess i'll go for it this is the safer
option possibly
but i think i could win
went out some material let's let's see
what this
how this uh imbalance works out
currently these two are
offset so i'm more focused on this guy
being
jumpy
what's he what's this guy going to do is
the main question
all right that's also another move but
i feel that
white doesn't win as much material going
this route
two nights now
i could use a knight on g6 safeguarding
my king as if it's a pawn i got a square
here as well
might as well start with this
does hit with tempo
i got this one covered
kicks kicks the rook off of the fourth
rank
um
i'm gonna plant this guy here right now
i don't know if i want to invite the
rook there
this this
all right i have this covered right now
my knights are doing a good job
let's go back
small improvements
look for checks as well maybe queen
right here is useful
i feel like i want to
secure some points around my king
feels like a healthy move
okay they may be eyeing up
rook there queen here
i have this
to defend
i think i'll take with the knight
if queen takes queen
all right
no stop checks
i miss a fork yet
oh why'd i do that i did miss a fork
knight g3
okay wait no it's still there
let's not give up just yet
oh that's a massive fork
okay i had it one move sooner
now i am up
a clean night
we got
another fork it's a super jumpy night
no stalemates
no way to challenge my rook
where's the mate
okay they're down on time
hello app1b
cpt
uh redress too thank you for the prime
resub
three months now appreciate that
let's go e4 what's going on very low
sodium
mr cash i am having a good weekend
how is yours
maybe we go for
the
the dubious
danish gambit
that's unusual
where's this guy going i feel like i
might be able to capture here already
still need another piece involved maybe
if the knight was already on this square
i'd be thinking a little different
let's get there this crossed my mind as
well okay that's a lot of pawn moves
all right i feel like
this is big trouble
so now this one i have the
the chop on f7
there is no king takes
or there is
i think king he had to go king e7 there
now this is a
a monster
material advantage
oh
i don't know
get another piece
into the mix there isn't a wonderful
discovery
bishop here queen here counter-attack
nope
knight is also pinned so this is uh this
is on this is on
plenty ways to do it when you're up this
material now
is there a fortress
no fortresses
this guy already has 21.
wow
got eight
all right
i guess i'll take the piece
or now let me take here
try and force the king into a disconnect
before taking this guy
maybe i take this one before the bishop
i feel like i want to take this first
and then
oh let's take here i'm on these two
okay the whole farm is falling
all right yeah that one
went off the rails a little
okay carlos
we've played a couple times already
we got
well i'll get the tempo prove my night
you're giving me it
all right get out there
scare me away nope
okay
i guess we take
go here if this there's that i could get
this guy back conveniently
all right my opponent's just going for
something simple
no advantage just uh just a just a
position
playable position for both sides
seems like we're both
ready to rumble
come in ending
i guess i put the rook here for starters
not sure how to improve
okay
we have mass exchanges i guess
okay i take here
that one
suppose i go here what's happening am i
winning a piece
feels like a piece
this this
this
wow wait a second
this this queen takes queen
rook takes queen rook takes rook and
then in the end there's that
wow
fancy
okay
huh
i'm spending a ton of time
am i missing something
all right
that just killed all my time there
wow
was my opponent really familiar with
that exact position that that move was
played so fast
i guess
wow
yep they're better
they got the file
i don't know move with this guy have
some imbalance
so watch over my base points
queen exchange i get a break in some
rook activity
we'll see
looking at this in queen f3
what about this move still
can i be a little fancy
the idea being this one i'm targeting
these two
queen exchange
ah i'm down a ton of time should be at
least even for
me um it feels like better for me
but 29 seconds is this is a big time
difference
i i spent way too much time trying to
i don't know my first calculation i
think was right that e5 wasn't working
but i
i stuck around with that
on h4
wow
okay this is
definitely winning
time
uh time really shouldn't be a factor i
don't think
got the active rook
oh what am i doing
could have promoted my pawn
wow
crazy
oh man
that was i felt like that would have
that could have really been a painful
loss if some silly time burner was in
there i i don't i don't have the sound
on so i didn't hear
sometimes i miss a move i missed a move
in that ending
i missed that my opponent moved
okay this is the pack leader who who is
this player
all right let's go with
maybe i could focus on d4 they've
there's a hole
there uh this is a time sensitive
position okay so they're not gonna get
d4 in because i have too much on it
let me go for this early maneuver
before castling it
i want to get i want to be able to pivot
on f8
and i don't know that it's useful to
ever play rookie 8.
i think it makes sense to immediately
dive in so that i'm at least a blink
away from flushing this night out of my
house
aggressive
very aggressive
very aggressive
now
if i don't play e6 right now maybe
bishop g5 is gonna hurt me
do i need to play e6 right now
let me go with e6
this also crossed my mind exchange
knights
okay i did not see that in betweener
i guess i'm uh
gonna head
queenside
i don't know
how do i liberate my bishop
let's start here
knight exchange bishop there
we'll see
i feel like i need
some breathing room
this guy has all the answers
all of them
i have this square covered
this is this is a move
here you're ready to go in that
direction all right let's castle
let's chop
get this tempo
so active man
i'm not sure what to do
this guy has an answer to everything
shutting down all counter play
all right
35 seconds
what's the assessment here
nobody knows
maybe put pressure on this pawn
hmm i had a pawn there
time time time
hang on
hang on
10 seconds
oh what am i doing
i should be able to pre-move everything
let's make sure we get all the pawns
this guy have a loss
yeah
it's really fast and speedy
i don't know seems like he's punching
above his weight there
d4
uh king on pre
thank you for the tier one resub seven
months
hey jerry thanks for the great content
thanks man i'd enjoy it hello skillex
um
no let's go with this capture
and here i played this recently in a oh
no i'm i'm i'm doing it wrong
that's when the knight is still on this
square and i could
challenge the queen i i've misplayed it
i'm thinking
um this is off
don't try this at home
oh well now i'm going to be worse
for a while
i don't know
i don't like playing with this iqp
it feels like a liability
in this
oh my goodness
[Laughter]
you might want to take that bishop next
time
what was i thinking
oh
the queen is hitting my bishop there
oh boy
this will be a miracle let me tell you
i somehow win this
that's not happening
oh
oh man
that horizontal clean move got me good
okay okay okay
and just how am i supposed to finish
developing
someone please inform me
because i don't have these answers
i'm thinking after this i could go there
that's not true
yeah
all right let's let's try and cut the
bishop off i need to get castled
oh okay at least i could castle
all right
um
maybe i'm threatening an amazing bishop
move how scared is black about a bishop
move
okay
all right hang on hang on night there i
got a fork a roni
maybe we could get an iqp position or no
an iqp an opposite color bishop position
what are you talking about
all right let's go here
we're threatening queen exchange and
mate well no not quite with my knight on
f3 i don't have any amazing discoveries
if the take twice on e5
i always have to watch out for this i
have to be prepared to play f3
yep
there it is
night there
not too much i could do about that
time time time
go ahead i dare you
i got something good if you do that
actually i don't
i've got nothing
that's a good move
the old underminer
surprised i even got this far honestly
and that b5 move let me off the hook
being able to castle
might as well take a pawn
might have to go for the queen exchange
soon
rook a4
i don't know we'll see
that one
let's see
i'd like to have my king on h1
i'd like to get off of this diagonal
i feel like this could come down to a
rat race right around now
we're basically in hyper bullet mode
all right i got a rook
about ready to get cut off
it's not getting mated
oh anything but that move
oh my goodness
oh
no idea
okay
where are we at
i got 24 i still have a chance to win
this tournament
not berserking back
i got nine lives let me tell you
there's no way i should have won that
but here we are
okay
no no let's jump around
chop once
chop again
let me go here
pressure there defense of the bishop
i want to be able to take
take here
flick in a check first
if the queen blocks i exchange queens
and then i have a fork on c2
okay
i gotta go back so
that's the
that's the square
also
um
okay let's castle
that bishop is so annoying
let's break here
i think my queen could be
well positioned on b5
that move
let me defend the queen
and also i'm ready to take and take on
b3
i imagine the knight wants to be the one
who recaptures
so what about now
gonna be a counter attack against this
point soon
it's not the most fun move to play
babysitting the pawn but
all my pieces are now contributing
snipe can't move just yet
i don't think
pressure on the b pawn is tying up these
queen there
you know what i might want to do
reposition
this
maneuver
thought about this as well
opponent only has 30 seconds
maybe it's a better idea to get this
pawn involved first
before demoting my knight
okay it's a little unusual
okay
prepare to take with the bishop because
now i'm ready to take the knight and
take on b3
rook there defends but now i could go
for this night maneuver
maybe i swipe the knight first
and then go for the night maneuver
yeah let's try this
get a valuable tempo
it might end up taking no
okay so i could take here
let's get behind the pawn
check
here
flight square
time
whoo
speedy player
okay got the w i have 20 no forget about
first this guy
this neck player what's the performance
rating yeah
almost 300 above
the rating
okay
what to do
let's go with e4
caro khan
all right let's go for an exchange carol
i'm gonna play against this guy
and get these two moves in quick
okay
so where's that guy going control the
knight
castle
fighting against the e5 pawn break
let's put this one in
i'm okay
i think if they have these two moves in
i feel like i should be all right if i
have to capture away from the center
okay
well i'll say let's go here
it's a little a little cluttered for
black queen doesn't have a wonderful
pick of squares
my bishop does a good job of cutting
into black's position
where does she go
okay
and the path forward is what exactly i
guess
we inch our way to a slightly more
active square
connect
rooks i guess now we could exchange
this guy's poison
all right how many exchanges do i want
maybe maybe i stop right here
and say if you take then i have this i
have a big pawn on e5
there's still that question mark over
the bishop
also since h6 is in there it's not so
easily
the knight isn't so easily kicked i have
a nice forward move with tempo
so i feel right around here
there should be a an attack nearby
this is no longer a wonderful purpose
with the rook on e1
and if i'm going to pivot i'm probably
going to pivot on f3
with my rook
so that there's the possibility to get
to the g file i could also now that the
the bad for good bishop has been
exchanged
uh i could think about this maneuver
and this knight will be a
a force
on the queen side
so i could consider this one
um
also these are
these moves are appealing
these these active moves with the queen
are met with queen g5
this knight is not doing anything
i'm gonna go for this lockdown approach
b4 knight b3 to c5
there he goes and there he will stay
if he's challenged i'll
it doesn't matter i'm going to sit there
and then be prepared to recapture and
have a connected passer
so
however you slice it once this guy is
here it's
i think there's almost always going to
be a long-term positive
all right so let's let's proceed with
this
so i'm expecting that one
but take towards the center
there's no pawn break with b4 maybe even
king walks in an ending might be there
although not how how do i even get to
that point
okay let me back up with the bishop
at least hint at this battery
if i could provoke this move
that should spell trouble for black
this rook will be doing wonders
i think this is a win
queen d3
yeah even if there is a pawn break
it's it's going to expose the king to
something
if we trade all the way down into a king
and pawn ending
i think this guy
is gonna
be the deciding factor i think it tips
in white's favor almost always
mention one
that's now forced and
let's put this guy here and there's
going to be an accident happening these
two are shut out of the game
just by the structure alone on the queen
side
oh queen side and center
no no good pawn breaks
you have these probing moves
this if that there's g4 you get the
brakes in
or maybe the most direct stuff this and
then this
probably working
and let's go with the pawn softener
see how they react to h5 yeah now we
this and then that and then this and
then this
a lot of good stuff
and there's a pin
do i even want that
check here
there the rook gets here
let me say let's let's just play with
this one
i want to play h5
this should be officially broken
and take
all right they're down on time
that guy is cruising along with 41.
that's a lot of points
all right let's get one more game in
probably not going to count
for the tournament
let's go with d6
okay
playing with c4 no c4
all right
um
all right let's go with this setup
a step out
to
to control both the knight and bishop
this construction i'd like to get an e5
let's see if i'm allowed to do that
or is white gonna play e5 no
all right so that was a critical moment
well i could have played e5 so now i get
this pawn
in there to challenge the duo
what was i gonna play after e5 i was
thinking knight there
i think i want to take first
okay
so now i like that this guy's unmasked
on unmasked
i think it makes sense to develop
with tempo
didn't think at all about grabbing that
point
and now i want to secure my bishop post
expecting rook d1 but this is a little
awkward maybe they're going for that
setup yeah
okay or or or this one hmm
okay that's an idea
okay let's put the knight here staying
out of the way i want to be able to
defend like this and this
okay
so now
i also was threatening that point
okay let's play here i think i'm
covering all my base points time
is a little off
this a4 move could help extend the scope
of both bishop and rook
what's that knight up to
not sure
let's start with that
pawn softener
c4
might become a hole i'm threatening this
and this something's got to give oh that
move
okay
i don't see any reason to hold off on
releasing the tension
alright if that i got to the seventh so
that's why they're taking away this
square is now weak though
could i take advantage of that
hmm
not sure what to do make a king move
i guess
maybe i should move this
let's go here let's get out of pins
move the bishop some maneuver like that
i don't know
i don't know i'm just making a quick
move not sure what to do
activate my bishop
not sure
maybe this now
if i did that sooner
there's a check my king's not in
in reach of the check
i don't know
might be in some trouble with my bishop
fortunately there isn't night h2
i'm under a minute
see how good this idea is
i'm going to cover this first
cutting off the queen from here
let's go one more
i should be looking at this trick
possibly
yeah i don't know what to do here
how to improve
maybe this and then that
30
seconds this is covered
not easy at all
not even sure what this move is doing
wow
pressure on g3
bishop should cover everything
i could have already promoted
what am i doing
wow
tight game
really close
all right
i'm back to tournament that's the last
one
took third
461 in there
some really close games
should have had at least
one loss in there at least one loss
all right
good games all
32
41 37 32
27 yeah
played uh
300 points above the rating there toto
dennis and second
all right there's your top ten looks
let's look at the top 50.
who else was playing
page two three
four and five
all right
fun as usual good games all